now a live look now from manny's glow
after dark which remains closed at this
hour after a gunman opened fire inside
the hookah lounge over the weekend
killing one injuring more than a dozen
others today we have an update an arrest
has been made good afternoon thanks for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas here's a look at
the suspect taken into custody metro
police says 44 year old lee wilson was
arrested yesterday now we're learning he
was recently released from jail in
another case and has quite a lengthy
criminal history
[Music]
one count of open murder and 12 counts
of attempted murder is what lee wilson
is facing according to clark county
detention center records
the 44 year old was arrested on tuesday
in connection to the deadly weekend
shooting at this hookah lounge off
sahara near maryland parkway it was you
know out of nowhere i didn't expect that
to happen the clark county coroner
identified 33 year old demetrius beard
as a victim killed in saturday morning
shooting that injured 13 others i don't
feel that safe when i go like out in the
parking lot customers and employees at
neighboring businesses tell us the
deadly incident is a black eye for the
historic shopping center that many have
been trying to clean up it looked like
that particular business didn't have all
the proper licenses or things in place
or even proper security most likely so
it could have been prevented according
to reports collected by the eight news
now i-team wilson has convictions dating
back to 2002 in 2019 he had six charges
in connection to trying to kill two
people in a plea deal he pled guilty to
one charge and was sentenced to 12
months and had recently been released
as wilson remains behind bars these
workers say they are not lowering their
guard so if we're here past hours of
course you know if it's dark we'll lock
up you know
then we have our last customers we'll
just let them out and just make sure
that we're safe